so yesterday on the world famous and
award-winning bonus show producer Pat
and I talked about the reality that
British prime minister Liz truss's days
may be numbered even though it had only
been like six weeks since she came to
power and indeed we woke up this morning
in the United States the news that
British prime minister Liz truss has
resigned after only 43 days in office
trust is a member of the conservative
party also known as the Tory party and
you started to get the sense that maybe
this wasn't going to be particularly
long-lived when the idea of cutting
taxes on the rich was first presented at
a particularly inopportune time given
what was going on in the British economy
and then very quickly abandoned it
already sort of wasn't looking
particularly good and then now indeed a
CNBC reporting UK prime minister Liz
truss resigns after failed budget and
Market turmoil that's putting it lightly
a writing that on September 23rd trust
is financed Mr Minister quasi cuartang
announced a so-called mini budget which
began a turbulent period for UK Bond
markets which balked at the debt-funded
tax cuts he put forward most of the
policies were reversed three weeks later
by the second Finance Minister Jeremy
Hunt that's already a bad start and
indeed now the resignation comes amid a
financial Market turmoil and a Revolt
within the conservative party as is
often the case in politics defiant until
the very end just a day earlier check
out this video listen to this audio
defiant
saying I am not a quitter
and of course we know what happened just
hours later this is yesterday Mr Speaker
I am a fighter I'm not a
I have
it in the National interest to make sure
that we have economic stability order
I'm going to hear the Prime Minister I
suggest that all members need to hear
the answer prime minister
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
I am a fighter
we have delivered on
price guarantee we have we delivered on
the energy price guarantee we've
delivered on National Insurance we are
going to deliver to stop the militant
trade unions disrupting our Railways The
Honorable gentleman has no idea and of
course ultimately what she delivered was
a resignation announcement this morning
very early U.S time uh morning time in
the UK let's take a look at that uh how
quickly political Fates can of course
reverse given the situation yes I can a
much a much more sober sounding Liz
truss this morning not deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party wow
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security a bit
late for that actually I will remain as
prime minister until a successor has
been chosen thank you yeah it's a very
very clear and definitive resignation
there this makes Liz trust the shortest
prime minister shortest lived prime
minister in the history of the UK the
previous shortest died rather than quit
so this is really quite significant um
Liz truss 43 days and prior to Liz trust
the shortest live prime minister was
George canning whose term lasted 119
days you have to go back to the period
April 12
1827 to his death on August 8 18 27. now
one perspective on all of this is that
this is really less about Liz truss and
Boris Johnson than it is about the
disconnect between the conservative
party
and the majority
of the people in the United Kingdom and
the idea is that trust was essentially a
scapegoat and so you could kind of take
it step by step well the Tory party has
been the Tory party for a long time of
course tax cuts for the rich it's like
Republicans in that sense no matter what
you see no matter what nail or screw or
tile or piece of flooring you see your
only tool is a hammer so you figure well
I'll take the hammer to whatever it is
even if it doesn't make sense to start
hammering a tile
um and the Boris Johnson resignation was
more about his particular bad acts than
it was about policy but then sort of
seeing the writing on the wall and that
this is really not the time economically
for someone with this policy the idea is
well it was clear that whoever replaced
Boris Johnson Liz truss or whoever else
uh Mr Bean right it was going to be if
the policies were those of the Tory
party it was going to be a sort of
sacrificial lamb it was going to be
escape goat whatever to go up there and
say yeah we're still going to do the tax
cuts obviously we're not that gets
abandoned they suffer and then they move
on and now whoever is next again this is
the idea whoever is next now won't
suggest the tax cuts for the rich which
would be particularly ill-timed right
now and maybe we'll be able to have a
longer tenure the other idea is all of
this this is just going to be a loop
until eventually the conservative party
is removed from power and that it's just
a matter of time and it's just a number
of scapegoats or sacrificial Lambs
between now and then I don't know but an
extraordinary bit of global news there
43 days as prime minister imagine if we
had this sort of process in the United
States that would really be something
hey I want to play a video for you that
is really really good because it brings
out a conversation that is a necessary
conversation to have you know how
Republicans love to say we have our
violent blue States and violent blue
cities and it's so dangerous to be in
what they call Democrat cities of course
it's not true
and yesterday or this might be actually
from the day before is this yesterday I
guess yeah this is from yesterday there
was a debate yesterday wherein sitting
Oklahoma governor Kevin's tit
um is being challenged by Democratic
Challenger Joy Hoffmeister and stit
tries the typical stuff uh Democrats are
bad for crime and Democratic states are
dangerous and he's they love to
scapegoat New York and New York City and
to her credit Joy Hofmeister points out
hey you know what Kevin uh violent crime
is higher in Oklahoma than it is in New
York and she's completely correct I'm
gonna give you the data this is not a
matter of opinion he simply says no that
can't possibly be true and there's
something that the audience does that's
very revealing about how these
Republicans think and behave take a
listen to this so let's talk about the
facts the fact is
the rates of violent crime are higher in
Oklahoma under your watch than in New
York and California that's a fact
well we'll have that fact checked by the
frontier superintendent it's also a fact
that medicines do you believe we have
higher crime than New York or California
that's why she just said
Safety and Security is my so Kevin's tit
says that doesn't sound right you you
people don't believe that right and the
cloud goes no no this is the way they
operate it just doesn't sound like the
very stuff we've been repeating so it
can't possibly be true right but it is
very much true these red state folks
have no idea that they are being lied to
and that blue cities and blue states are
being scapegoated for no reason that has
any connection to reality they don't
have any idea how violent their states
are if it doesn't sound right it must
not be wrong and of course the reason it
doesn't sound right is because they're
constantly lied to about it but it is
true if you look at the rate okay the
rate is crimes per population of course
a state with a dramatically higher
population is likely to have more a
higher number of violent crimes because
there's Millions more people in a lot of
these high population States but what we
care about is the rate we care about the
rate it's sort of like if I say more
people died of covid in Florida than in
Wyoming
that doesn't really tell us much because
Florida's population is so much larger
similarly if I say there are more crimes
in New York City than in Savannah it
doesn't really tell us much because New
York City has so many more people if you
look at the rates Oklahoma was most
recently ranked 15th highest in the
country for rate of violent crime and
New York state was 26th it is without
question
that Oklahoma has a higher rate of
violent crime than New York State and in
fact this isn't really rare if you look
this is public data I don't I don't
claim to have any kind of Monopoly on
the data if you look up top states by
violent crime
uh rate
of the top 10 states you've got seven
very red States
one purple State uh Nevada
uh and then you've got Washington DC and
then there's like one more purple stage
I guess it's two purples it's seven red
States two purple States in Washington
DC which is in a state but it's a
territory it's red States it's red
states with the highest violent crime
rates now you could say well David sir
you're being deceptive forget about
Oklahoma and New York State what about
Oklahoma City and New York City fine
dude make the same comparison in 2022 so
far the Oklahoma violent crime rate is
40. and New York City is 28. that's this
is a one to 100 where a higher number
means more violent crime New York City's
violent crime rate is significantly
lower than the violent crime rate in
Oklahoma City and by the way the
property crime rate is also dramatically
lower in New York City 25 versus 60 in
Oklahoma City they don't care about the
facts
Democrats run New York City it must be
more violent well okay not true now I I
can't get off of this topic without
mentioning one other important thing
this entire conversation is also skewed
because in general cities have more
violence because of more population
density cities tend to be more
democratic and often in blue States but
red States also have cities and they're
often significantly more violent and the
safest big cities are all in very very
blue States but there's this base rate
bias where Democrats tend to prefer to
live in cities versus conservatives and
that's a systemic reality even still the
numbers are not what these Republicans
claim them to be so Kevin's tit laughing
it off absolutely true uh what Joy
Hoffmeister said there
um Mike Pence failed former vice
president Mike Pence was interviewed uh
yesterday and he was asked if Trump is
the nominee in 2024 will you vote for
him now remember
trumpists are the people who were
shouting hang Mike Pence on January 6th
Trump is the guy who completely turned
on Pence because Pence wasn't willing
nor Able by the way wasn't willing as
Trump says to do the right thing to try
to steal an election for Trump that he
didn't actually win and here is what
Mike Pence has to say when asked about
this and if Donald Trump is the
Republican nominee for president in 2024
will he vote for him oh
well there might be somebody else I'd
prefer more
okay
you know what I can tell you is I'm I
have every confidence that the
Republican party is going to sort out
leadership all my focus has been on the
midterm elections and it'll stay that
way for the next 20 days but after that
we'll be thinking about the future
ours and the Nations and yeah so first
of all he's sort of saying I might be
running I mean to some degree what Mike
Pence is saying is there might be
someone on the ballot I prefer like
myself when he says we're going to be
thinking about our future and the
Nations he's saying I'm going to be
thinking about what I want to do in
2024. regardless of that there are two
interpretations here and they can both
be correct on the one hand
it is very clear that Pence is off the
Trump train and is trying to figure out
the right way to get off uh without
derailing his own political career
that's number one on the other hand
his supporters were saying they wanted
to hang you and the strongest thing
you're willing to say is there might be
someone else who I would prefer more so
you can interpret this however strikes
your fancy right on the one hand maybe
the strongest anti-trump language we've
heard from any of the major figures of
the Republican party for the last year
and a half on the other hand his support
Trump supporters wanted to hang this guy
and this is all that he's willing or
able to muster up it's all pretty sad
but an indication that the 2024
Republican primary may become very
interesting very quickly right after the
midterms that are now just uh 19 or 20
days away let me know what you think
find me on Twitter at dpacman we'll take
a quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
some interesting legal news that I want
to go over relating to the ongoing legal
troubles of the failed former president
and his associates first and foremost
very interesting report from Bloomberg
prosecutors believe that they have the
evidence to charge Donald Trump on the
basis of the investigation connected to
the search warrant served at Mar-A-Lago
let's take a look at this Bloomberg
report Trump prosecutors see evidence
for obstruction charges no decision on
charges has been made by doj in records
probe that's an important detail a bunch
of tweets were floating around yesterday
sometimes I wonder can people actually
read news articles as soon as this was
published yesterday all sorts of tweets
started floating around a decision has
been made Trump is getting charged the
the sub headline is no decision on
charges has been made in that records
probe timing politics and debate over
charges are among the considerations and
that's an area of significant concern
that we should all be worried about and
we will get to it in a moment here's
what Bloomberg rights a group of justice
department prosecutors believe there is
enough evidence to charge Trump with
obstruction of justice but the path to
an actual indictment is far from Clear
the team that's part of the classified
records probe has not yet made a formal
recommendation to Merit Garland who
would ultimately approve or reject such
a move according to people familiar with
the matter it's also unlikely officials
would bring only obstruction charges
amid several other Trump investigations
into potential crimes now this is the
part that I don't love
in addition while some FBI agents oppose
bringing such a politically charged case
As Trump considers a 2024 presidential
bid others support action said the
people who asked for anonymity because
this is not yet public agents however
don't make final decisions the justice
department has publicly indicated
obstruction is part of its probe into
the mishandling of classified records
noting there was probable cause for the
charge in the August 5 FBI search
warrant application for Trump's
Mar-A-Lago estate no charges are likely
to be filed or publicly revealed before
the November 8 elections and perhaps
only after the Christmas holiday the
people said one other uh note here Frank
figluzzi former FBI assistant director
for counterintelligence said quote of
all the things Trump is being
investigated for around the country
obstruction of justice is a slam dunk
and I think he's going to be indicted I
don't see why a charge of obstruction of
justice couldn't be filed by the end of
the year so listen uh charge gym it's
time okay we've had enough of this it's
really simple consider I mean forget
about Georgia forget about sdny just
focusing on this case investigation
alone
um did the uh did authorities know that
Trump had these files
and then they went to him and said
you've got to return these files yes we
they knew he had them and they asked for
those files to be returned did Donald
Trump return them the answer is no we
know that because they found files when
they executed the search warrant at
Trump's Mar-A-Lago do we now know that
Donald Trump was aware that they had
files directed staff to move them
directed a lawyer to lie and claim that
they had been given back I mean all of
these obstructive acts yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes so is it time for an
indictment of course it is of course
this of of course it is now what I'm not
thrilled about is this discussion about
FBI agents do or don't want the charges
uh levied because it could impact the
midterms so they're going to wait until
later but then it could impact Trump if
he decides to run in 2024 or whatever
listen
if they're
are charges that follow logically from
the evidence
not charging Trump because it might have
a political impact is just a political a
decision as saying let's charge him in
order to make it have a political impact
the a political thing to do here is that
those in law enforcement look at the
evidence they compare the evidence to
the law and they decide is there
sufficient evidence that a law was
broken such that we are going to Levy
charges you don't calculate the timing
based on political effect or whatever
else think back to the 2016 election by
the way where then FBI director James
Comey did one press conference about
Hillary Clinton's emails and then as far
as we knew that was it there weren't
going to be charges coming etc etc and
then right before the 2016 election for
some reason that we still don't really
understand James Comey does another
press conference about Hillary's email
miles and we now believe we can't say
any one thing led to Trump winning and
Hillary losing but it was certainly
another little factor that served as a
reminder of oh yeah that thing even
though obviously no charges are coming
that may have pushed some people away
from Hillary Clinton into Donald Trump
if there was any politically oriented
politically motivated timing for the FBI
doing something it would be that
here we have enough probable cause
for the search warrant to be executed we
now have colloquially speaking as lay
people all of the elements that make up
obstruction by Donald Trump knowingly
directing people to lie and hide
documents all these different things and
at this point this idea of well we don't
we don't necessarily want to charge him
because it might affect a future run for
president he hasn't even announced well
opting not to charge for that very
reason is also a politically motivated
decision and it's absolutely pathetic it
is just as politically charged not to
charge someone because it might hurt
their chances at winning an elected
office as it is to say well let's
deliberately charge him now if the
evidence is there and the investigation
has been completed and it points to this
person likely committed this crime then
you just have to Levy charges and that's
it we will see if it happens it's not
going to happen before the November
election we it's abundantly clear at
this point in time but if and when it
happens when will it be another legal
problem for Donald Trump that I want to
briefly talk about and then we're going
to move on to other things a federal
judge has found that Donald Trump lied
under oath about voter fraud in Georgia
while trying to overturn the 2020
election results now we're Switching
gears before we were talking about the
federal investigation that is connected
to the search warrant at Mar-A-Lago
that's the last story this is a
different situation now Business Insider
summarizes the statement by the judge a
federal judge Wednesday said Trump lied
under oath about voter fraud claims in
the 2020 election not a big shock
Trump quote knew that the specific
numbers of voter fraud were wrong but
touted them both in court and to the
public this is per Judge David Carter
Carter made the determination in a
ruling ordering a republican lawyer to
turn over his Communications to the
January 6th committee
this goes back to December 4th of 2020
and I know many of you remember this
many of you don't many of you have
chosen to forget it and I understand I
understand why on December 4th 2020
Trump's legal team filed a lawsuit in
Georgia State Court alleging that Fulton
County miscounted thousands of votes
they also contested the state Court's
proceedings in federal court this was
one of dozens of complaints that Trump
and lawyers filed in various courts
later that month Carter wrote in his
ruling Eastman this is Trump's lawyer
Eastman said in an email
that although Trump had quote signed a
verification for the state court filing
on December 1 he had since been made
aware that some of the allegations and
evidence proffered by the experts has
been inaccurate for him to sign a new
certification with that knowledge and
incorporation by reference would not be
accurate he added the emails show that
Trump knew that the specific numbers of
voter fraud were wrong but continued to
tout those numbers both in court and to
the public this is also not the first
time that this has been suggested so
it's abundantly clear that in every
single one of these cases you have
claims that are made that normal people
who look at data and evidence doubt but
we ask ourselves
are they making these claims out of
ignorance or are they making these
claims knowing they are false claims in
order to deceive others and we don't
necessarily know right away but then
slowly but surely we come to learn that
these claims are made knowing that they
are lying in the Mar-A-Lago doj
situation did Trump believe that they
really had given back all the documents
I don't know maybe we later find out
Trump knew they had not given back all
the documents because there is a report
that he had an employee move documents
at Mar-A-Lago oh okay so he was lying he
was lying deliberately to deceive
arguably an obstructive Act
same thing here okay at the beginning of
December Trump signs off on we believe
these are the numbers of fraudulent
phony and valid votes from Georgia maybe
Trump believed it at that point in time
we then get testimony and statements
under oath that actually later on when
Trump continued to sign off on this
stuff Trump had been advised that what
he was claiming and signing off on was
not actually the truth unfortunately
Georgia state law says that the
punishment here
is up to one year in jail
and up to a one thousand dollar fine or
both this is
um uh 2020 Georgia Code title 16 crimes
and offenses chapter 10 offenses against
public administration Article 4 perjury
and related offenses and it says
punished by a fine of not more than a
thousand dollars or by imprisonment not
less than uh one not more than 10 years
or both but the particulars of this uh
likely point to no more than one year in
prison uh one year in jail rather you
know there is this question is whether
as to whether the American justice
system should really assess fines as a
function of income because one of the
realities that we have in the justice
system in the United States with such
drastically different Financial
circumstances for people
are that the same five thousand dollar
fine can be a completely unpayable
bankruptcy inducing fine for many in
society and then such an insignificant
find for others in society that it does
nothing whatsoever to actually punish a
bad act and so there are countries that
do this with speeding tickets for
example we've talked about it before I
believe Norway might be one of those
countries but I don't remember
completely offhand but there is a real
question as to whether fines should be
assessed based on ability to pay with
some upper and lower limits certainly I
think that reasonable people could agree
to that so not a particularly auspicious
day yesterday for Donald Trump from a
legal standpoint but when we continue to
ask the question well but then so what
what's coming is anything coming
I think we all are in the position of
saying we don't really know
you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to welcome back to the program today
Mike rinder former senior executive of
the Church of Scientology and the Sea
organization also author of the new book
a billion years my escape from a life in
the highest ranks of Scientology Mike
great to have you on again as always
thanks David it's wonderful to be back
so I mean in the interests of treading
some new ground right up front since the
last time you've been here you know a
lot of things have happened in the world
that don't relate directly to
Scientology I think there's this feeling
among some that the Church of
Scientology right now is somewhat
diminished both in notoriety and maybe
in strength because it's not really in
the news as much as it once was is that
a fair assessment or do you disagree
with that oh no I think that's a very
fair assessment David I think that
Scientology has been dwindling as to its
overall numbers and its influence
primarily due to the internet also due
to a lot of media coverage you know
information is the enemy of high control
organizations and groups and Cults and
information is available to anybody that
has a computer or a phone and can Google
and you know these days nobody buys a
pair of shoes without Googling are these
the best ones yeah uh so it's very
difficult for Scientology to
get new people in and so
their numbers are diminishing but I
wouldn't say that that is diminishing
their revenues yet
because what happens is you get
organizations that are you know in a
bubble of US versus them mentality when
the walls start closing in the people
inside feel more desperate that they
have to do more give more money but like
become more active and and involved in
order to save their particular cult from
Extinction so probably Scientology is
still raking in you know millions and
millions a week but that is an
unsustainable model because eventually
those people run dry and you have to
have new people coming in and that is
not happening and you know you you add
to that the problems that have come up
you know there's been this political
race for the mayor's office in Los
Angeles which is turned into a
mudslinging contest on who can hit on
Scientology the biggest
and the Danny Masterson trial now
started a lot of things uh
are looking pretty dark in the world of
Scientology right about now in terms of
the numbers you know I I in Lawrence
Wright's book going clear
uh right writes that internal claims
often allude to millions of members I've
read numbers as small as 30 000 globally
which which I don't even know it sounds
very low but maybe it is that low what's
your sense of the membership at this
point well my estimate at this point is
around 25
000. oh wow that's the lowest I've heard
anyone even stayed well there's a few
others uh like who have that similar
opinion
um uh Aaron Smith Levin and Chris
Shelton and Jeffrey Hawkins Jefferson
Hawkins all of whom are former seaorg
people uh you know high level Executives
in Scientology who had access in one way
or another to information about
membership Scientology
inflates the are membership figures by
claiming that anybody who has ever
purchased a Scientology or Dianetics
book therefore becomes a member because
we have their name and address from when
they purchase the book and over 50 years
there's been millions of people who
purchase them so Ergo there are millions
of scientologists but
if you look and see things like
Scientology claims to have 15
000 members in the Tampa Bay area or in
Clearwater right you know the numbers
vary but when Mark bunker who was a a
very avowed opponent of Scientology ran
for city council the Clearwater City
Council
he won with 5 000 votes so they couldn't
round up enough votes to prevent Mark
bunker in their you know Enclave of the
highest concentration of scientologists
anywhere in the world so that pretty
much put paid to any claim that they
have millions of members they they never
have had millions they may have had a
hundred thousand or a couple of hundred
thousand back in the 70s or the 80s but
today no way
you um you escaped in 2007 if I recall
correctly which is roughly like 15
getting closer to 16 years ago do you
think that you were still on the radar
of the church are you being tracked how
closely do they I mean like will people
from the church see this interview for
example that we're doing right now
absolutely David you'll probably get a
letter from a lawyer before you manage
to put this up on anything
um oh boy but but
well it didn't happen with the last one
hopefully so hopefully not this time
yeah but now my book is out so they're
going a little crazy you know they're
they're uh
paying for Google ads to any search of
my name shows up with a Scientology
Google ad putting up new smear videos
and smear sites and sending legal threat
letters and you know all the usual
shenanigans that Scientology gets up to
I'm certainly not gone off their radar
in fact I came like right back into the
center of it the day my book was
released
um one of the things I think is
interesting about your story and for
people who want the details of how you
ultimately kind of changed your mind
about the Church of Scientology and
ultimately left we go into that in
detail in in our first interview one of
the interesting conversations we're
having now is generally about the
deprogramming as the term sometimes is
of people who are in a cult it might not
come as a shock to you that many in my
audience believe that trumpism is a cult
and they see the people at the Trump
rallies uh with with impossible stories
and contradictory beliefs and and an
inability to ever kind of puncture the
bubble in in which they they exist and
the question is okay so like what can be
done to accelerate or help people along
in in that process what have you learned
in your experience about what can be
done from outside the cult to help
people in it see the truth or something
closer to the truth well from my
experience it's very tough it is very
tough to penetrate that barrier but in
the case of Scientology what I tell
people to do is use the words of elrond
hubbed as the entrance point to get them
to look you know Hubbard
said a lot of things many of which are
contradictory and on one hand he said
you know do everything that I say and
read and follow it exactly on the other
hand he said believe what you know what
is true for you and look don't listen
and you know uh think for yourself all
of which are very contradictory to the
actual teachings of Scientology but if
you quote those things to a
Scientologist and say look Hobbit says
you've got to think for yourself Hubbard
says you've got to look don't listen
Hubbard says what's real for you is
what's real for you not what someone
tells you is real so don't you have an
obligation to follow what Hubbard says
and actually look at information outside
of that bubble
that has limited success yeah I don't
know David anything that actually is a
guaranteed Silver Bullet there's no no
garlic for this vampire that works 100
of the time time it just is sort of
the one thing I do know that doesn't
work is to tell them they're stupid
right tell them that they're that
they're completely ignorant and stupid
and that they just are our fools because
that plays into their own stereotype
that the rest of the world are the ones
who don't know what's really going on
the other thing that outside not as
applied specifically to Scientology but
that's often mentioned by critical
thinking folks and Skeptics and this
type of thing is that just like bashing
people over the head with facts also
isn't very effective so like as applied
to Scientology that would be like
explaining the scientific and
possibility of some of the origin story
that's told or whatever is your
experience also that talking about the
impossibility of that is not effective
yes oh that that that is useless you
can't approach someone who has beliefs
and try and undermine their beliefs
the only thing that I have seen that
works is the demonstration of the acts
in the real world that are contradictory
to those beliefs like if you take
someone and say you can't believe that
there is a virgin birth
then you're going to have a real hard
time with most Christians convincing
them that there is no such thing as a
virgin birth because they believe that
that is the case if you say that their
uh look this this uh priest
molested this child and has been
convicted of that and the church covered
it up it's a much harder thing to
overcome that and just go well I don't
really care because I believe in the
Bible
so you got to kind of find the things
that are demonstrable in the real world
that are
and but you know even that doesn't work
most of the time I mean the the
justifications and explanations as to
why things are the way they are or how
they're rationalized can be pretty
pretty out there I mean I see these
people and you know I I watch your
channel and a bunch of other stuff and I
see people that you know JFK Juniors
alive and well and like uh you know yeah
like what
so one of the um one of the things
that's commonly told by people who were
sucked into organized crime is that the
way that they ended up all the way in
started relatively innocuously so it
might start with hey can you just run
this envelope across town for me and
there's this kind of process through
which you're before you know it you're
much further in than maybe you ever
would have imagined yourself to be
similarly you know to to take trumpism
there's a lot of folks who in 2017 if
you said hey you know by 2020 this guy's
going to be suggesting injecting bleach
to treat uh you know a a disease that
you haven't even heard about yet a lot
of people would have said that will
never happen there's no way but slowly
we get there we get their drawing on a
hurricane map with a sharpie and it gets
more and more and more insane do you
find that that takes place with the
recruitment of scientologists oh
absolutely I mean David that's what my
book is about my book is about my
immersion into the the world of
Scientology to the point where I was as
dedicated and as convinced that
Scientology was the only route the only
salvation for all of mankind as anybody
could be I mean I became the the
international spokesperson of
Scientology I was like the head of the
dirty tricks Department that dealt with
the enemies of Scientology I was 100
percent convinced not that I was doing
bad but I was doing good that I was
saving the world that I was saving every
man woman and child on planet Earth and
that this was the most important thing
that could possibly be done and
I I hope that anybody who reads the book
will understand the parallels between my
experiences in Scientology and what they
see with other people who act insane and
what were some of the small asks that
that they start with well it really
started for me when I was a child and my
parents got involved and they started
saying to me look the solution to this
problem is contained in what Ron Hubbard
says is the answer to this problem do
what Ron says and your world view
becomes lrun Hubbard solved every
problem of every person on Earth and all
of mankind and laid it all out for us
and if we're too stupid or too lazy to
find out what all those answers are and
apply them then more full us we need to
be dedicated because he has come up with
the answers for everything and as soon
as you start down that
path that there is one person who has
got the answers to everything you then
go into some of the answers and those
answers become themselves the next step
in that immersion process you know there
are a lot of them in Scientology a big
one a huge one is that you have to be
responsible for your own condition and
this is a
you know a platitude that Hubbard came
up with that has some applicability and
validity to it but when you take it to
the extreme that it's taken to in the
Hubbard circumstance it means in
Scientology if you get run over by a car
it's your responsibility you are
responsible for for the condition that
you that you've got yourself into right
and that means that at some previous
time you ran over someone else with a
car right in order to feel the need to
be punished and punish yourself by
getting run over by a car right this is
the ultimate in victim blaming and it is
also the ultimate in no matter what bad
thing may happen to you in Scientology
that Scientology may cause or do to you
it's your fault it's not scientology's
fault right yeah and of course those are
the types of arguments that are
completely unfalsifiable there's
absolutely no way to argue that it that
it's untrue
um the book is a billion years my escape
from a life in the highest ranks of
Scientology we have been speaking with
the book's author Mike rinder Mike
really appreciate your time today thank
you David it's great to see you again
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
you know we've become accustomed to sort
of lurid anecdotes of all kinds being
told at right wing rallies oh this
undocumented immigrant did this thing or
that thing or the other thing and sort
of used to the bizarre uh Craven
political advantage of many of these
Republicans they are now up against such
an example themselves because of a guy
that is being dubbed the Maga
masturbator I I
I don't know what to tell you guys a
republican Arizona candidate has been
caught masturbating outside of a
preschool and the story is absolutely
Bonkers HuffPost is reporting Arizona
Republican candidate arrested for
allegedly masturbating in a truck near a
preschool it's in none other than the
infamous Maricopa County Arizona where
officials say it's too late to remove
the the alleged perpetrator Randy
Kaufman from the ballot in the race for
a College District board dozens of you
emailing me about this the story is
roughly as follows again as reported by
Huffington Post Kaufman was arrested on
October 4th
but suspended his campaign earlier this
week following reports of his arrest
he was running for the governing board
of the Maricopa County Community College
District and was allegedly caught
masturbating by the County's Community
College Police I f'd up Kaufman said to
an officer during the arrest according
to the police report which is quite a
document which you can find online and
read the report says the incident
started when an officer approached
Kaufman's parked vehicle and saw that he
had his pants down I'm not going to read
it exactly as it is written but
basically the officer was able to
ascertain by visual observation of the
individual's genitalia that there was
manipulation taking place and it was all
um in view of a nearby bicyclist and a
preschool where little kids were playing
outside
when confronted according to the officer
Kaufman apologized and said I'm sorry I
effed up I'm really stressed really
really stressed and then said are you
going to put that in the report which
indeed the officer did yikes
uh don't you see how alarming that is
the officer responded there are children
nearby people passing on bikes and in
cars where they can look and see what
you're doing
notably in a Facebook post from May
Kaufman said he wanted quote our
children protected from the progressive
left
Kaufman was charged with public
indecency but 12 news in Phoenix
reported that Kaufman could also face a
possible felony charge because of his
proximity to the preschool so listen
what is the story here is the story that
Republicans endorse this stuff no it's
not and one of the things that
Republicans have been insisting upon and
we saw I can't even name all of the
people that did it Kerry lake has done
it Marjorie Taylor green has done it
um there's so many they they love to say
the Democrats are the party of
pedophilia and child abuse and all of
these different things and of course
they don't even have examples of it here
we have an actual Maga Republican who is
caught doing exactly what they love to
say the left welcomes and now they don't
want to say it has anything to do with
their party I'm willing to concede that
this is an individual actor but what we
can't continue allowing them to do is to
insist without evidence that the left is
the party of all this you know demonic
cabal of pedophiles and this that the
other thing without evidence when this
is not the only story like it that we
find about Republicans I'm not
I don't think my audience is so gullible
nor do I disrespect my audience so much
that now I'm going to say this behavior
is endorsed by the Republican party but
the point is their story about the left
their pedophiles and all this different
it's we've got to do something to not
allow them to continue repeating that uh
because it's the type of thing where you
go no no we're not and they go wow
that's exactly what the pedophiles would
be doing they would be denying it
there's got to be some way out of this
nonsense and there are too many of these
stories about right Wingers uh to go
unnoticed at this point in time one
other little note on Herschel Walker we
continue uh talking about Herschel
Walker the Georgia Republican Senate
candidate and his fake badge
um I have sort of like good news and bad
news I guess the good news at this point
is that it's really pretty transparent
that is badge is fake this goes back to
his debate with Raphael Warnock Rafael
Warnock correctly accused Herschel
Walker of lying about being a law
enforcement officer at which Point
Herschel Walker took out a badge during
the debate now it certainly could be a
badge that was handed to him by some
sheriff and he claims that it is but it
is meaningless it confers no law
enforcement power
um Herschel Walker has not been and is
not today any kind of law enforcement
officer authorized to do anything at all
well Herschel Walker did another one of
these campaign events yesterday and at
this one
he said that when you laugh at his badge
you're laughing at the military and
you're laughing at law enforcement that
doesn't make any sense Herschel but here
he is saying it
beds I love my bands when they laugh at
my parents they laugh at every military
every police officer in the country how
why that doesn't make sense Herschel
they because they're the one who gave me
the best because I support them they
support me so what we got to do is tell
them if they don't like our police leave
go somewhere else we're not holding you
here it's not that we don't like the
police you are not a police officer
think about this unhinged word salad
this country
he seems completely disoriented
if you laugh at his fake badge which
confers no law enforcement Authority
whatsoever
you're laughing at our military and
you're laughing at our law enforcement
and then he says if you don't like our
law enforcement just leave
nobody's talking about how his fake
badge connects to any particular view
about the police
he is not a police officer it has
nothing to do with liking or disliking
liking police officers we're not even
really laughing like we sort of are I
mean it's cartoonish and funny in a way
but we're finding it sickening and very
sad but you know what truly the saddest
part of all of this is I I it's
embarrassing to even mention this
the race is even closer now than it was
before the badge Fiasco before the
abortion and badge Fiasco Raphael
Warnock was winning by nearly three by
nearly four points warnock's lead is now
smaller it is now only about two and a
half points think about what this says
about in this particular case Georgia
voters that before the entire abortion
Fiasco started
it was roughly 48.44 war knock ahead
for a very brief moment Walker dropped
by like a point
and the race has now tightened to where
the difference between these two
candidates on the one hand incumbent
Democratic senator Rafael Warnock who
understands policy who understands
process who understands reality
is leading Herschel Walker by only 2.4
Walker doesn't understand anything
pulled out a fake badge claims to be a
police officer claims to be authorized
to work with police if something happens
which doesn't even mean anything
that claims to be pro-life with no
exceptions and yet paid for a woman's
abortion and then urged her to have a
second abortion which she did not do
and it is 2.4 points this says as much
about the Georgia electorate as it does
about the candidates and our voicemail
today has to do with exactly what I'm
talking about here
our voicemail number is 2192 David P you
can call anytime and ask about anything
here is a really interesting question
that relates directly to what I was just
saying about the voters of Georgia
hi David it's James I just wanted to
know um how do you feel about voter
shaming I know that um
you know
uh a couple things uh Kyle and
um Mike figuerado and a few other people
I think um
The Young Turks are generally against
motor shaming like they don't criticized
Trump voters because they voted for
Trump
but they'll sometimes criticize people
who voted for Trump because of the wall
or because
of you know the fact that he said
Banning banned Muslims or you know
Mexicans or rapists and all that
um how do you feel about voters do you
think it's productive do you think it's
fair
um or do you think it's better to just
stick to criticizing the politicians
um
what do you know because uh I I
basically I I want to find out the best
way okay yes right so what's so so
listen there's two things going on here
all right if you're asking me do I think
it's in bounds so to speak for on
programs like mine to be very Frank and
candid and direct about the fact that
there's a lot of dumb people in this
country and many of them don't know what
the hell is going on and they're just
Bamboozled by these politicians with
obvious lies and they fall for it and
they vote for them and how do they even
put their pants on in the morning how do
you balance a checkbook
if you are so ignorant about just basic
things you're being lied to on I have no
problem as a commentary on this program
saying stuff like that and in fact I've
said there's really three main groups of
trump voters there are people who just
don't know what the hell is going on
they don't know they don't know what
Trump policies are they just don't know
anything and they were kind of like
tricked they stumbled into voting for
Trump
there's people who are what we might
call like bad people they do understand
the Trump policy and they understand all
of the things that happen as a result
and all the people that Trump policy is
terrible for and they say I like it and
I'm going to vote for him anyway
and then you've got the third Group
which is people who vote for Trump out
of some selfish priority well yeah I
understand exactly who and what Trump is
but his tax plan would save me money so
I'm going to vote for him those are the
main three groups of trump voters I've
been totally upfront about that so I
have no issue about shows like mine
doing that
on the other hand
I am aware
that as a matter of pragmatics
and effectively deprogramming people
from for example trumpism
if I were running a campaign
right and I was Trump's opponent
I don't think that shaming Trump voters
would be the right way to win them over
right I would take an approach that
would be something more like listen
I understand that because we have so
much work to do in this country to
really make it what it could be
I understand the desire when something
different pops up and Trump was
different
to find in that a reflection of your own
desires about the reality that this
could be a better country I understand
that but we tried it and it failed
and I can tell you exactly what would
make this country better and it's what
I'm offering and I welcome you to come
to me no matter who you voted for last
time around that framing which is you're
not shaming anybody you're actually
saying I get what was going on that made
you say I don't know this is different
maybe it's better
that is more effective than saying
there's a lot of stupid people here
there are a lot of stupid people here
and for a program like mine it's
different than if you're running a
national campaign so that's my view on
voter shaming I hope I'm sort of
explaining it clearly we have a great
bonus show for you today sign up at
joinpakman.com and I will see you on the
bonus show
foreign